bonjour à tous curieuses et curieux vous
aussi ça vous déprime quand vous êtes
tout seul isolé chez vous à ne voir
personne quand vous êtes malade un virus
apparaît et tout est dépeuplé
surtout pour des êtres sociaux comme
nous les humains mais d'ailleurs et vous
dans la nature ça se passe comment
l'équipe de scientifiques s'est
intéressé au comportement de certains
groupes d'animaux sociaux frappé par des
maladies et apparemment cas de crise il
vaut mieux être malin comme un singe à
je sens que cet épisode va nous filer la
banane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les humains sont des animaux sociaux on
voit au quotidien nos vies nos cultures
nos modes de communication sont basés
sur les changes le contact et
l'interaction et nous ne sommes pas les
seuls certaines espèces de fourmis de
poissons d'abeilles et même de homard
sont aussi des animaux sociaux des
scientifiques étudiant les macaques se
sont rendu compte que ces animaux
tissent des réseaux de relations
sociales complexes permettant la
diffusion d'informations au sein d'un
groupe
figurez vous que les macaques peuvent se
partager de vrais savoir-faire entre
générations d'un seul groupe
on a observé qu'ils étaient capables de
se transmettre des techniques de
nettoyage de patates douces mais aussi
les habitudes voire des traditions une
vraie culture
donc autant vous dire la distanciation
sociale à la base c'est pas vraiment
leur truc non plus
[Musique]
oh tu te laver les mains on est prié et
pourtant des scientifiques ont étudié le
comportement de ces mêmes animaux
sociaux ayant observé que dans la nature
il était capable d'appliquer des
solutions simples et efficaces en cas de
maladie dans un gros attention spoilers
vous n'allez pas voir d omar se faire la
bise qui a pu se dire bonjour ou des
poissons faire les gestes barrière de
corail
par contre vous allez bien voir des
singes faire de la distanciation social
chez les mandrills les scientifiques se
sont rendus compte qu'en cas de maladie
dans un groupe c'est la distanciation
sociale qui prient pour protéger
l'ensemble du groupe et chez d'autres
singes comme les macaques une équipe de
scientifiques a réussi à modéliser et
observer directement l'impact de la
présence de ces agents pathogènes dans
le réseau via la modélisation du groupe
ici en bleu un groupe de primates st on
remarque en rouge un individu malade et
lorsque la contamination s'étend le
groupe réagit en s'éloignant et en
isolant les primates contagieux pour
protéger le groupe et contenir la
maladie
et oui on va quand même pas à prendre un
vieux singe à faire de la distanciation
sociale et chez les insectes aussi ça
fourmille de solutions en cas de maladie
les scientifiques ont administré un
parasite chez certaines fourmis d'un
groupe et ils ont alors observé que
celle-ci adopté certains comportements
étonnants pour s'adapter et pouvoir
continuer à échanger des informations
sans utiliser le contact direct entre
elles
ils ont remarqué que les fourmis malades
saute haut placés en quarantaine et que
les fourmis san utilisaient des gestes
barrières
plus question de se toucher avec les
antennes pour communiquer elle utilise
des phéromones et forment un cercle
barrières autour de la reine pour la
protéger
hop hop hop hop hop jeune fille toi tu
passais pas passer c'est juste en tire
le premier
et ça ne s'arrête pas là les
scientifiques ont découvert que ces
comportements sont adoptés chez un tas d
espèces du règne animal comme un genre
de règles universelles pour se protéger
alors pourquoi ne pas s'en inspirer
puisque nous sommes aussi des animaux
sociaux
finalement notre compréhension humaine
moderne de la propagation des pathogènes
et de leur gestion à une histoire de
moins de deux siècles alors que
l'évolution et la nature ont utilisé des
centaines de millions d'années pour
affiner des solutions à ce défi crucial
alors faisons leur confiance la nature
est une source d'inspiration incroyable
alors que vous soyez tendance macaques
fourmies où omar soyez stratégique pour
vous et tous les autres tous les moyens
sont bons pour se protéger et pour
protéger la nature aussi
si toi aussi tu aimes les amis vos
sensations et la bisque de homard abonne
toi